hello everybody hi how's everybody doing
yeah so um quick show of hands how many
people are traveling from the Bronx all
right that's cool
how about Brooklyn all right Queens all
right
Manhattan all right so we all right I'm
Staten Island I almost forgot poor
Staten Island yeah so we have
representation from all five boroughs
this is great
how many people here have come to
Rockefeller campus before yes oh my god
so you're all repeat customers this is
great um do you remember at all what
this campus used to be before it was
Rockefeller University who has who knows
what kind of farm sheep farm that's
right just a little bit of trivia right
in case in case that's ever relevant in
your life moving forward I don't know
sometimes you go to like trivia nights
at like in some like places I don't know
if they have New York city-based trivia
all right so my name is Jeannie
Garbarino I'm the director of rocky to
use science outreach and I'm really
thrilled that you guys are all here to
share in some pretty awesome science and
so before we get we go into the talk I
just want to tell you a little bit about
rocky to you
firstly you can find us on various forms
of social media including snapchat
although we don't have our own filter
we're working on it they keep on denying
us for our own filter but we're getting
there but if you want to put us on snap
or follow us on snapchat you can or if
you want to find us on Instagram I don't
have anybody even uses Facebook but
we're rocky to you under score also on
Twitter and our hashtag is rocky to you
additionally we have a lot of programs
that you can return to after you
participate in this so if you're
interested we always have the lol series
on every third Friday of the month and
our
next one will be in December on failure
so we talk about science and some of the
in some of the sessions but in other
sessions we talk about like things
related to science and failure is one of
them and so that's a pretty good thing
to talk about and we'd love for you to
continue your amazing attendance streak
additionally we have applications open
for two research programs the first one
I want to tell you about is lab jump
start ok this is a program that goes
from March all the way through August ok
and so that is a free program you get a
stipend for both the March the sort of
the after-school portion of it as well
as the summer portion of it but you have
to commit you know for the entire time
and it's 21 weeks so it's a it's a
really good program it helps to get
everybody who who hasn't had any
research experience it gives you the
fundamentals of doing science research
and then you're paired with a research
mentor in the summer time to do a 7 week
project ok and so this is a really great
program if you are interested in getting
your feet wet and really learning how to
do research our second program is a
summer program called the SS R P or
summer science research program those
applications are also open the
difference is you can just apply to this
one whereas in the JumpStart program you
need to be nominated by a teacher before
you get your your application ok any
questions on any of that stuff ok so but
that's good so if you do have questions
please come see me I'll be outside after
this a couple of other housekeeping
notes it would be really great if
everybody finishes their snacks in the
crinkling of their bags before our
speaker comes on because it can be a
little distracting so feel free to just
like quickly get your bags opened your
sodas opened or whatever you have going
on and try to be a bit quiet while the
speaker is going so that it's not
crinkle crinkle crinkle the whole time
additionally after this we're going to
have a series of networking activities
that you can come out and participate in
and after the talk we will ask you to
give us some questions but we're gonna
make sure that you raise your hand and
get the mic so if you've been here
before for an lol you know the drill
right and yeah so that's it so now I
have the pleasure of introducing dr.
mark Stowell who actually does a lot of
this research in the rock edu science
outreach laboratory and so we're really
pleased that he's headlining this show
tonight because he's such a close
collaborator of rocky to you and an
awesome supporter of high school student
research so I'm gonna hand it over to
you mark thanks a million for being here
and yeah we're looking forward to
hearing you oh thank you Jeannie it's a
great great turnout
Friday afternoon I'm going to tell you
about some amazing projects that I've
had the opportunity to do with high
school students and in these projects
you'll see they got a chance to make
scientific discoveries they attracted a
lot of media attention the media loves
it when high school students are doing
science and they change the world so and
my hope is that you'll get some ideas
from this and when you're when you go
out you'll think of projects of your own
that you might do so what we do is kind
of a combination of the nature Channel
and CSI oh no if you if you watch any of
those shows so we're interested in
nature finding out what's going on there
but we use the DNA methods that are the
same crimes that are used at crime scene
so we work with little bits of DNA
traces of DNA and we use that to better
understand nature and all of our work is
based in New York City and we've had an
amazing series run of projects that have
turned up some really surprising
discoveries I got started in this
actually with when my daughter was in
high school I got started working with
high school students she was in high
school I was working on something called
DNA barcoding which some of you may have
heard of it's a way of identifying
species by DNA you don't need to have
the whole organism just a little bit to
identify it and she said well can we can
we identify sushi with DNA I said yeah I
think so I don't think anyone's done
that that'd be an interesting question
so they went out this is their project
they went shopping and they like to eat
sushi
they took little bits of and that you
only need a little bit like that to get
a DNA analysis and I helped them package
that up and send it off to a laboratory
you have to course keep your samples
straight keep your records good we sent
it out for DNA sequencing got the
sequences back and then we matched these
to the database just like your matching
you find DNA at a crime scene it's only
good if the person whose DNA it is is in
the database and so what they found was
a quarter of the samples were mislabeled
and it was always mislabeled as
something better something more
desirable or more expensive it was
pretty much everywhere that six of ten
grocery or fish markets and two or three
restaurants and for instance something
sold as white tuna was really mozambique
tilapia so very expensive fish the cheap
fish sold as an expensive fish this
attracted a lot of attention
they were Kate and Louise's story was on
the front page of the New York Times
they were on morning television and they
were in newspapers really around the
world this is a cartoon from the Korean
Daily News I think you can see there two
girls looking at a fish on a plate with
a magnifying glass and the chef's being
led away in handcuffs and that's sort of
the idea that the something wrong with
the fish that they they discovered and
without the student involvement it
absolutely would not have gotten the
attention that it got and this did
appear in scientific literature but it
was the popular literature that really
made it
have been meaning The Times and the
television radio this is a quote that
from Time magazine if you're paying for
white tuna and you're eating tilapia I
think you'd want to know that that was a
summary of that their story is now in
college textbooks and they have their
picture in college textbooks so again a
lot of impact from that the samples were
and their results were part of a
scientific paper that was in Food
Research International and this study
because he got a lot of attention it
really helped make other changes and one
of them was it led to much bigger
studies this is a study that Oceana is
just a nonprofit group did across the
country hundreds of samples and they
found really the same fight about a
third of seafood is mislabeled and these
things prompted the Food and Drug
Administration to adopt DNA barcoding as
their official standard for identifying
fish so they went from high school
students to national exposure or an
international exposure and really having
a lasting impact this was such a success
we did it went again the next year we
did a project called DNA house and we
asked Brenda tan and Matt caustic just
find anything you could find in your
house that might have DNA in it you know
how good is DNA and they tested they had
amazing results things like if you get a
feather duster and it's made from
ostrich feathers you can get ostrich DNA
out of that if a dog biscuit that just
you can analyze that and you can find
out what kind of meat the dog biscuit is
made from so you really don't have to
have a piece of the original animal they
did test some food items and there that
got picked up by the course they found
things that were mislabeled something
there's labeled as sheep's milk cheese
was really just cow's milk and something
leave
sturgeon caviar this from a very
high-end delicatessen in the in
Manhattan was really from Mississippi
paddlefish which is good deed it's just
not sturgeon and here's though it says
you can see two high school students
were part of this study they were in the
New York Post it's hard to get into the
New York Post unless you've really done
something wrong but they this was pick
one of the things they found was that
they tested some cockroaches or pieces
of cockroaches their work I won't say
where we found them but they were
genetically distinct from any cockroach
in the database and it seemed like it
might possibly be a new species and that
intrigued the New York Post that was
such a success we tried again and this
time looking not so much at they at the
animals but it at plants and grace Young
and Katherine gamble and roane corporate
car went around got tea like tea bags or
or loose tea from the school cafeteria
and from stores in the neighborhood and
they got regular tea which is made from
the tea plant as well as herbal teas
which have a variety of things in them
and we got the testing done at new york
botanical garden by damon little and
they found particularly the herbal teas
the third of the herbal teas have things
in them that aren't on the label now
sometimes it turned out it was things
like chamomile which is a good thing to
put in tea but it was a major ingredient
but it's not on the label and then there
are a lot of things like lawn grass and
a whole variety of weeds that are in the
herbal teas so that this their work is a
basis this is a scientific study that
was in nature scientific reports you can
see their co-authors on that they were
also in the New York Times
there that study led to a much larger
study done up in Canada you can see that
the T study was the first reference from
that and this really annoyed the people
that make herbal products because
because they said you're giving us a bad
name but the fact is that a lot of them
are mislabeled and this was really help
bring that to the floor and this led the
New York State Attorney General to sue
the herbal manufacturers for and since
then the the verification process has
changed it's obviously in the interest
if you're selling an herbal product to
to know what you're selling and to be
able to authenticate it so that really
had a big impact we did something a
little different for the next project
for this is working with joy so Xia was
a senior at Hunter high school we wanted
to follow up on that cockroach story and
it turns out there's not a lot of
research on cockroaches but no one wants
to even pick them up or go near them but
what we did was we wanted to find out
are there really different species in
New York of the really large cockroaches
is it called American cockroaches and we
set up a website and we emailed everyone
we knew and we asked them to mail us
cockroaches not not alive and we had to
check first because it turns out it's
okay to put a cockroach in the mail
because it's not officially a pest
because it's everywhere so it doesn't
matter whether you spread it around and
it's not considered wildlife if it's
wildlife then it's under the protection
of the US Fish and Wildlife so it's
alright to put a cockroach in the mail
and for the next year every time these
are all letters that contain cockroaches
so I would come into work and open the
mail and we had a wonderful selection of
cockroaches from all around New York
City from other parts of the United
States and people heard about this we
weren't
I'm from Argentina in Australia Korea
and China from Iran so that was a great
in and the the project was it's five
four or five years ago and people are
still mailing me cockroaches so I have
some up in the lab and they're very
disappointed when I tell them this study
is closed I said well I'll put it in the
freezer so we have a lot of things in
the freezer it turned out the
cockroaches they're different types and
they're a little bit different by the
neighborhood but they all interbreed so
that's one definition of a species so
they're they're probably like New
Yorkers so they came here from different
parts of the world and now that they're
here they're mixing and matching and so
this was the scientific study you can
see joyce was a co-author on that and
two interbreeding among these deeply
divergent lineages these genetically
distinct forms we had some wonderful
publicity this was in Wired magazine
what's it like opening your mail and
finding dead roaches this was Russian
television and they came and filmed that
here at Rockefeller actually right over
here on the student lab and among none
of my still getting cockroaches but
among certain of our friends this is
every time they tell me they see me they
think of cockroaches so there's such an
unusual idea so this is what I'm going
to talk about what we're working on now
and this is a really exciting new
technology with DNA so this is working
with before working with something
that's sort of a recognizable specimen a
bit of tissue a wing of an insect here
we're just collecting water and we're
analyzing the little bits of DNA that
are floating around in the water and it
turns out this is work that was started
and initially in France that there's
enough little bits of DNA in the water
that you can identify things that live
there just by taking like a glass of
water
so it the DNA that's floating around is
called environmental DNA meaning it's in
the environment it's not part of a plant
or an animal and these are does anyone
know what fish this is it's a striped
bass okay what's that okay I discovered
one thing with this project is the only
names of fish that people know and I was
the same with this our fish that we eat
what we do eat striped bass but they're
actually turns out they're dozens of
different species of fish that live
right around New York City so this is
our research site that's Manhattan and
you can see parts of Brooklyn and Queens
and the Bronx
there are a lot of people that live here
but it turns out there are a lot of fish
and this is actually an important
environment for fish and the harbor is
cleaner than it used to be and or one of
the results of that is more fish they've
started to come back here and then the
fish attract things that eat fish so
we've been some of the collecting we do
this is Rockefeller right here is right
outside here in the East River we
started this with Eamon nesaf and Alden
Liang Eamon may be here I don't know and
first we went up to Central Park and
went to the Harlem beer and we collected
water up there we said this is the first
time we're going to try it I thought
they can't possibly work it but it
worked amazingly well the first time
around so we got little bid these DNA
out of there and we amplified the DNA so
we could look at DNA of vertebrates
which all fish are vertebrates and then
we see can we match these very short
sequences to the library to GenBank
which is like our database
and we got seven species of fish and
this these bars give you an idea some
how much of the DNA of that fish is in
the water so and there's a lot of into a
lot of roughly if there's a lot of DNA
of the fish then there are a lot of the
fish but that's area where a lot of
people are trying to do research with
that we also found other things human
DNA is actually everywhere we go in the
water I mean I haven't been out to the
middle of the Atlantic but anywhere
along the east coast other dog you can
imagine rats rats of the Communist
wildlife we got their DNA in the water
if you sample around then and some birds
and also spends its time around the
water so that was worked amazingly well
that first summer if we compare it to
traditional methods like putting a net
in the water or fresh water they do a
thing called electro fishing which is
you have a generator and you put an
electrode in the water and you stun the
fish the electrocution hopefully that
they survive and that way you can pick
them up and count them so it's sort of a
primitive method but that's still how we
survey fish in fresh water and a nice
overlap with what's found either by
electro fishing or by seining by using a
net and we found some things that are
not we're not found in these same water
by either of those method so that was
good so then we said we'll just try some
other
you
right up here in the East River and
these trimmers not really a river it's
really a tidal channel and the water
flows back and forth between harbor at
the south end and Long Island Sound at
the north end
[Music]
[Music]
it makes a s
you
[Music]
[Music]
you
[Music]
you
[Music]
you
[Music]
[Music]
you
[Music]
you
you
you
misconception of what it was
you
all of our food and somehow there's some
idea that DNA is shouldn't be there
the I'd say that's the biggest
misconception or or lack of knowledge
really in the the fact there's enough
DNA in the water
you
oh all right down here um I was
wondering how long DNA stays intact in
the water that's a really good question
we need more experiments on that I'd say
it lasts days two maybe weeks if it
lasted forever we wouldn't see any
difference from one season to the next
and we'd get eventually do you know the
DNA from a fish that lives in Asia would
make its way over here and the ocean
would be more like a bowl of soup but
it's kind of a Goldilocks quality it
lasts long enough that we can detect it
as I said sort of probably in the days
maybe more than a week but not so long
that it's not a that it's just not a
good record um here we go over here you
get a microphone and a water bottle
always your motivation for just research
on DNA it's a I read about it a few
years ago the first paper looked at as
done in France and they took very small
samples of water much more like a
quarter of your water bottle and they
found they use it to show that frogs
were living or not living in a pond
and I I don't know I saw that I thought
right away this is gonna be a big thing
now that's that paper was 10 years ago
so it takes time for these and and the
the the techniques and then to be
disseminated but as I said I like
finding out things that no one else
knows no one else knows every time we go
out and sample the water I'm excited to
see what we get from the talk people
that are interested in the environment
around New York
city I think anyone there's a lot of
general invite interest in the
environment and protecting the
environment among adults and we tend to
think the environment is the thing out
there but in fact we're in the living in
the middle of a natural environment and
we want to do things that can help it
and just to add I mean that there are
lots of groups that want to use this
technology for their own personal
surveys you know people that are
interested in the health of for instance
the Gowanus Canal or maybe the Bronx
River or maybe which is only the only
freshwater river in all of New York City
by the way so I mean this this you know
with high school students doctor Sokol
is actually pioneering a super useful
technique that can benefit people at all
different levels so I think you know
that's really important okay let's see
we have a question sorry what what's
your favorite part when you're
conducting an experiment I guess when
you get to the part of it where you like
you open the book and you see what you
got with the and depending on the
experiment that happens at different
time sometimes you get a computer file
and it has lots of sequences in it but
you don't know what they are and but
then when you match it it's really like
you know pulling back a cloth and seeing
what's underneath and yeah sometimes we
get nothing but that's the favorite part
I have a question over here
the way we're analyzing it we're
amplifying the DNA so increasing the
amount of DNA and we're targeting
vertebrates so that's a very there's
lots of other DNA in there there's
bacterial viral plants and as well as
the invertebrates like crabs
the way were we decided to focus on on
vertebrates and those things are
interesting too there are a lot of
groups doing this most of it so far in
the u.s. just the way things developed
has been done in freshwater there's a
lot of work in there Great Lakes looking
for invasive species there are a lot of
species they're already in invasive
species in the Great Lakes and there are
other ones that are just at the edge and
the fisheries managers there they use
this routinely in the oceans it's still
known not many people usually to work do
anything in the ocean you need a boat
you have to go and that would be
interesting too holy moly all right we
didn't get anybody from over here yet do
you have any examples of some data that
you found very surprising well
conducting your research you saying data
that's as I said I well first of all
it's all surprising to me because it
just it still doesn't quite make sense
to me that in a small volume of water
there's enough DNA to tell you you know
it doesn't different fish there in the
neighborhood the I was surprised we
could find the dolphin DNA relative to
the number of fish you know dolphins are
predators
and if you've done any ecology you know
there are lots of prey animals and then
when you get in up top of the pyramid
the biomass of a predators is much
smaller and I was surprised so I was
pleased but I was surprised with that um
how can you use your findings in the
future how can how can you use like
based on your findings how can we use
this in the future
the main way it's going to be used
is to understand much better what lives
in the ocean if we talk about fish for a
minute
really our knowledge is really quite
primitive if you were to compare to say
what we know about birds
we have counts of every bird species on
the planet how many individuals there
are we know where they migrate we
monitor them every year in the ocean
it's like we go like this we do his test
here we do a test over there now the
oceans are bigger but in the reason we
do so few tests and then we try to
extrapolate from that is because it's so
expensive it's ten thousand dollars a
day to put a boat in the water with a
net in the ocean so if we can do it
through water samples and eventually
it's going to be autonomous it's going
to be undersea robots that are going to
be out there collecting the DNA or
sitting on the bottom and maybe
analyzing it there and sending a signal
to the surface with different do you
name the water is there anything you
might have seen in the DNA besides the
species I'm not sure the good answers
that question other than we are just
looking at fish there's it's not enough
some people say well as the DNA damaged
you know from the environment or
mutagens carcinogens in the environment
we couldn't tell if that was true or not
because the pieces were looking at her
so small that you would really and and
they may have been damaged just by being
outside of the animal but that might be
an interesting question but for that
you'd have to look at the animals
themselves all right so we had someone
who's been raising their hand for the
entire time so here you go
how would future climate change affect
the DNA in the water I I think the
everyone who works on the environment or
ecology is concerned about climate
change you know we don't know what
exactly is going to happen
this gives us a way of monitoring what's
happening as I said we just don't know
much about fish and fish populations but
we don't but now if we can do this kind
of thing and we do it every year
and we collect the data just like you
measure the temperature like you do a
weather report but you have now and you
and they collect temperature from many
different weather stations so if we can
collect DNA information over the course
of a whole year from many different
state will be able to see our species
moving north
are they disappearing are they changing
their routes so I think is is it as a
telling what climate change is doing to
the animals it can help us alright so
here you've had your hand up but we're
out of water bottles so they'll ask
questions ok so I know you're only
looking at vertebrates for now but can
environmental DNA also be collected
outside of water yes you can
I mean waters convenient way to get it
you can do from the air there's DNA in
the air it's a little not not a lot of
it but that's one thing you could do and
from soil those would be the main places
it's been done so those would be all
alternatives it's you don't get the like
a stream kind of integrates the DNA from
the whole distribution the whole
watershed of the stream and when you're
doing a soil sample you probably don't
get that you're getting a much more
localized answer but it's gonna be an
interesting answer um if I can add to
that so there have been studies done on
the subway where they basically looked
at the microbial makeup of every single
subway stop and they also did air
samples with looking for DNA and you
know how sometimes when the train comes
and you feel a little breeze right
before the train comes yeah well in that
breathing I'm really sorry I'm gonna
gross you out right now
do i or don't I do i or don't I okay in
that breeze is a DNA that originates
from rodent feces welcome to New York
City everybody all right next question
we have someone over here all right
settle down I'm sorry that I i riled you
up here all right let's let's hear it up
for the next question okay how have you
communicated your findings with other
scientists I'm sorry could you say it
again
how have you communicated your findings
with other scientists that's really
important I mean that's kind of half of
science it's not just doing it but it's
communicating it I mean there are
several ways one is publishing a
scientific paper and then try to
publicize the fact that you did a
scientific paper for each of these
projects we've also invested a lot of
effort into getting publicity not
scientific publicity but getting
publicity in the mainstream press
because in the end the reason we do
science or were allowed to do science is
because of support from the public so I
think communicating those findings to
the public is in as wide a way as you
can and this is dey's information that's
understandable so that's another way and
then the third I'd say is local
networking we have a discussion group of
researchers and funding agencies from
around the New York New Jersey area to
find out there are a lot of people
concerned about the health of the Hudson
what can we do or how does our
information help them question right
here you said that the DNA lasts only
for a few days or weeks what happens to
it after that excuse me what happens to
yeah well it gets smaller and smaller
and you know she
you know and you're you know it just
gets shorter and shorter and that means
harder and harder to detect you can the
ancient DNA studies where they're
getting DNA out of like soil samples or
sometimes bone but times from they can
get DNA bits there are fifty thousand
years old it's about that's very short
that's about those are 10 or 20
nucleotides long this piece is about 200
so it just gets shorter and shorter and
then eventually it's completely broken
down into the sort of chemical
constituents can't have a question up
here in the corner what difficulties did
you face while doing this experiment I'm
sorry what type of difficulties did you
find why doing this type of experiment
difficulties well first of all
collecting the water to do that whole
year that looks like some of the days it
was really bad weather and just to go
down to think oh my god are you gonna go
down to the East River I'm gonna go out
to Coney Island I've been out to Coney
Island when you put a bucket over the
side of the pier and it just blows you
know straight out I had to put weights
on it to get it to go into the water
that's fun in its own own way the main
part of there's a part of lab work that
it's it's very meticulous and you know
you're doing like working with these
tiny little volumes and you have to do
it over and over and you have to not
make a mistake so that's that's a hard
part I have a question down here okay so
this might be complicated but like
exactly how many species did you find
like throughout all of your like DNA
findings like for fish about a hundred
so that includes the samples from South
Jersey as well as
the East River and the other samples
that were there and we have out of that
I'd say 20% when I say a hundred I know
it's a distinct DNA but I don't actually
know what the species is I know it's
some kind of Ray or it's but it's not in
the database all right so we'll take two
more questions you'll have to fight it
out what kind of limitations are there
to using your method compared to electro
fishing and st. signing yeah the biggest
limitation is we don't get any
information on the age or the size of
the fish so is the DNA coming it could
even you know from a little larval fish
and they're just lots of them or is it
coming from you know very large adults
that's things that if you're trying to
assess the health of a population you'd
like to know so that's a inherent
limitation in this this approach okay
there you go
so about how is this DNA sampling
technique applicable to I could see for
sampling or like more oriented on the
muck like the microbiome in said okay so
is this a DNA sampling technique more
oriented it's like a macro scale DNA
like macro scale organism DNA sampling
or and like categorization or is it also
applicable to act more you know
bacterial stuff I got in the water and
how that's that's a good question it's
the the procedure we follow is really
adapted from microbiome studies where
they're looking at bacterial diversity
and we took that same approach and said
okay we're gonna look at vertebrate
diversity so
same-same approach alright so let's give
a hand to dr. Sokol so I'd love it for
you guys to just hang out outside for a
little bit we have a couple of cool
activities some true-false crib you
questions on DNA and yeah so thanks and
don't forget to look us up Rockefeller
edu for slash outreach and apply